as more people go online to look for
love the FTC is warning that romance
scams are rising fraudsters often find
their victims through a dating site app
or social media more than 21,000
Americans reported falling for these
scams last year according to a new
report they lost a total of 143 million
dollars in the process that's up from
eight and a half thousand reports and
thirty three million dollars lost in
2015 this comes amid growing privacy
concern surrounding personal information
on the Internet
CBS News contributor and wired
editor-in-chief Nicholas Thompson is
here just in time for Valentine's Day
why are these dating app scams
increasing I think it's a couple of
reasons one I think there are organized
gangs or groups that have figured out
how successful they are it's like
anything on the internet there's a kind
of scam people learn how to do it they
get good at it they make lots of money
and then eventually we learn what it is
and we counter it and then a new scam
develops so it's partly that and then
partly it's dating sites dating apps
they prey on our emotional
vulnerabilities it's a situation where
we've given up lots of data we're
emotionally vulnerable and so therefore
were susceptible marks so that's why
this is growing even being a mark though
I can't imagine falling in love or even
hard for somebody who I've never met or
never even talked to Nick I know and
that's the way most of these scams work
where somebody approaches you on a site
wherever they approach you you start to
type and then you develop an emotional
relationship without meeting in person
or even talking but that absolutely does
happen it's gonna happen do I know I'm
talking to you how do you know you're
talking to me we're not a scammer
yeah well the best way is if you can
figure out a friend of a friend or
someone who can verify their identity
that's the gold standard if you can't do
that you look for other clues ready-made
a friend of a friend if I'm talking to
somebody I don't know how well it's
connected so a lot of these dating apps
you connect through your Facebook
account and it'll say you have these
mutual friends and you can call okay but
that's that's hard so what you do is you
look for clues in the conversation you
see does it actually seem like they're a
real person does it seem like the person
they say they are if you ask them a
question do they give a response that
seems genuine I was just somebody was
trying to target me last night and so I
was DMing them back trying to figure out
him they were said they were based in
album and target you how Nick
don't you get these all the time so
somebody goes into my direct messages on
Facebook it's clearly a stock photo
image of a woman and they say hello what
are you doing and normally I just block
and move on this one I reversed image
searched so I took the image I
downloaded on my phone I uploaded it you
could see it was on all sorts of sites
across the internet so someone had
clearly taken an internet a photograph
of a young woman from the internet and
put it on a Twitter account and then was
DMing people so I deemed back and the
person said they were in Alabama and
pretty soon they were using not
particularly American grammar it was
clear English was not their first
language so it was kind of an obvious
scam right and that's not what people
are falling for they're falling for more
difficult scams if you read there were a
Clemson fan which is a total average the
average person apparently uses 40 apps
on their phone so what are what do
consumers need to do in order to make
sure we use these apps safely right I
think you want to use reputable apps
apps that you've heard of that your
friends have used that people who have
good experiences and remember online
dating is a great thing many of these
apps like develop real relationships
America's so reputable apps you want to
make sure you have good password hygiene
right don't repeat the same passwords
that will prevent you from getting
hacked and preventing breaches and then
you have to make sure you kind of step
out before you get too emotionally
engaged in a conversation but I know
someone who was on match.com which is a
very reputable site this is an older
individual and she was targeted
developed a nice friendly back-and-forth
with somebody and then that person
started to ask for money someone had
fallen ill and ill in the family this
happens to a lot of people I think the
best advice is that if somebody starts
to ask for money or it starts to feel
weird
stop and ask a trusted friend show them
the conversation explain it to them pull
yourself out of that emotional vortex
and then you're much less likely to get
tied up this varies though to say yeah
that's that's the other reason why
people should have equal marks yes just
to be clear though something like
match.com has screening procedures match
sure that people can't catfish you
whereas what you're talking about
happening on Facebook through messenger
is a much more seedy kind of non
screened kind of thing but you can also
you can create fake accounts on whatever
service you want and you can pull
pictures you can pull information from
other people and you can create fake
accounts absolutely our regulators on
top of this we mentioned the FTC is
warning users
FTC's on it today yeah they should they
should really be working on this
absolutely okay well I have a boring
Facebook page compared to having people
back I don't look at the DMS on Facebook
so only when I'm prepping for segments
like this yeah we always keep you
working even on Valentine's Day
Valentine's Day to you to you and we
should also mention Wired's March cover
story welcome to mirror world mmm is now
online it's intriguing